all right let's move to something else i
mentioned this um
story about clarence thomas and i have
to tell you it's a little bit upsetting
aaron rupar who's a reporter left-wing
reporter
has dug up a pretty incredible story and
i think this is damning i have to say um
you may have already heard about some of
the revelations about jenny thomas who's
clarence thomas's wife and it just so
happens that we know clarence thomas was
in the hospital earlier in the week and
um when he's in the hospital we weren't
sure about his condition and thank god
it seems like he's okay but at the time
there were conflicting reports could be
a serious medical thing and and right
when he's in the hospital that's when
the media starts releasing all this
information about his wife
you might almost think like they're
trying to kill him because they've
waited until he's in the hospital to
come out with this attack on his wife
um
but the uh the damning revelations about
jenny thomas is that she's a
conservative and she believes things
that lots of people on the right believe
and she's had the gall to um
to talk about those beliefs if you can
believe it
and it's all it's all pretty terrible
but that's not the big news um this is
the clip that was making the rounds and
a lot of left-wing reporters were were
retweeting and stuff but listen to this
clip that rupar found
the best part of being a justice
it's first of all it's um
it'd be impossible
without you i'm i have to be honest i
mean it would be
um
it's sort of like how do you run with
one leg
you can't in the
um
it makes it whole
when i have my wife
my god
he loves his wife
this is
this is incriminating i kick him off the
supreme court this put
arrest them both they have been married
for for decades
and they still deeply love each other
that's that cannot be allowed in america
that's that's uh we can't allow that
kind of perversion
he wants to tell you about the left that
they they really think that that's
damning somehow
that he loves his wife
and and why is it actually it's actually
quite sad because so many of these
people aaron rupar and and the rest of
them um they've never they don't know
what a loving marriage looks like they
didn't see it in their own homes they
didn't grow up with one
you know they grew up in broken homes um
these are all a bunch of like latchkey
kids who grew up in broken homes and uh
and they just never seen it and now
maybe they're in relationships or in
marriages and they they they are in a
bad marriage themselves and it's just
this self-perpetuating cycle
and so when they encounter
a loving marriage and they hear the
kinds of things that a man who loves his
wife will say about his wife they're
taking their they're in shock they can't
believe it it doesn't make anything it
doesn't compute
i mean just think about how they reacted
all those years to uh mike pence and
still do to mike pence and and his wife
another damning revelation that um mike
pence doesn't go on like dinner dates
with other women because he's married
and they still that that
that secret came out five six years ago
they still haven't gotten over it they
cannot believe it's like what are you
what you're saying that you
when you're married to a woman and you
love her then you you want to be with
her and not some other women woman and
you don't date other people what
fidelity loyalty i don't just it doesn't
compute
um
to any normal sane person you listen to
that clip and you and what do you think
oh wow well that's that's i admire that
as a myself married 10 years i i look to
that that's uh that is my my goal to be
in that position at that age
you just you like clarence all of the
things
this is like especially with clarence
thomas
um
anytime a video clip comes out of
clarence thomas
and it's supposed to be something that
makes me dislike him every single time
it only makes me like him more i think
oh wow he's a great guy it seems like
there's not a lot of those in dc so it
is a little bit hard to believe but
apparently
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated